we are talking holiday cocktails
jennifer mckenzie is a mixologist here
in las vegas and she is here to kind of
show us some fun things that you can
make for the holidays to kind of spice
it up a little bit and i love the
variety so
just about something for everyone oh
yeah good morning las vegas first off we
have the herring cola
now the herring cherry liqueur is
actually a 200 year old
cherry liqueur we're gonna go ahead and
pour off two ounces of that
we're gonna top off with four ounces of
coca-cola
now you're a professional so you know
about how much two ounces is but for the
rest of us one shot glass or two shot
glasses you can actually use a [ __ ] if
you need to use a [ __ ] that's yeah
we're gonna do a little lemon squeeze
this is good for any occasion
so next we have the caravan negroni here
we have the coit caravan gin it's a
smoky tea distilled gin made with
caravan tea it's cardamon spice and long
pepper so that's a little bit different
than a regular gin which has that
juniper flavor yep okay so this one's a
little smoky yes and it's also vegan
friendly we're going to go ahead and do
one part pour on that we're going to do
one part campari
and we're going to go ahead and top that
off with a little orange slice
now that's a sugared orange slice yes so
it's a little extra yes
so you don't have to worry about making
them nope don't you combine them now
this is so it would be smoky but maybe a
little sweet
no not sweet it actually just with the
little orange slice it adds a little
sweetness to it but it's a little smoky
you're not gonna get that juniper scent
you're gonna it's made with tea so
it adds a little different something
different yeah absolutely so here for
dessert we have the choco vine this is
actually a french cabernet it's made
with dutch chocolate
you can serve this on ice or you can
serve it chilled
now this is really good after meal
so this is your dessert this is
definitely
with
your
little mint to give it a little
ambiance now we have these awesome three
cocktails but they're all in different
glasses so jennifer i mean you're a
professional here does the glass make a
difference the glass doesn't really make
a difference i mean you just use what
you have but honestly i mean the only
thing is like traditionally you want to
put in a groni and a rocks glass wine
you want to put in some kind of wine
glass but it doesn't need to be you know
just use what you got but this this
makes it seem fancier because you have
the long stem so there you go and at the
holidays you know you want to you want
to spice it up a little bit okay so now
all of these things where can you get
them you can actually find all these
delights at your local las vegas liquor
stores so that makes it easy to go
shopping you can get the accoutrement
there as well wonderful jennifer these
are great ideas do you have a favorite
i like them all she likes them all okay
i'm gonna go with dessert so cheers
everybody cheers
okay yum yum yum and in case you missed
them here's the recipes
herring cola you just need two ounces of
the herring four ounces of cola scored a
lemon and if you want a wedge for
garnish makes it pretty and then how
about the caravan negroni it's one ounce
of the herring an ounce of the coit
caravan gin that was the smoky gin and
then a little bit of campari maybe an
orange peel sugared orange something
yummy we're going to post those recipes
on our website so just a little
different than your average holiday
cocktail chocolate
chocolate
one glass i mean you know it is kind of
filling but
filling that all it does to you
i have a holiday don't you know she said
it was kind of feeling
feeling feeling yes fair enough
good fear
i'm sorry i wasn't paying super close
attention what was that herring was that
a a
yeah it's an alcohol it's like a cheery
kind of like a cordial okay yes and i
don't know if i can call it little core
but it's got like a cherry flavored not
a herring fish not a herring it's a
hearing hearing hearing i've got to work
on my hearing